methane gushes from a well dug more than
a century ago and abandoned since the
1950s
141 cubic meters of pungent greenhouse
gas per day
it was recently uncovered in cleveland
ohio in an apartment complex for elderly
low-income residents many of whom have
complained of the smell for years did
you ever smell the gas
yeah but others smelled it more than i
did but it was definite it was awful
now a team from the non-profit well done
foundation is hard at work plugging the
leaky well for good when we're done and
we're walking off of this project that
we've stopped the emission of 5 000
cubic feet of gas per day you know you
start to multiply that by
by weeks and months in decades
it's very significant abandoned wells
are a huge problem by government
estimates there are more than 2 million
of them in the u.s and possibly many
more whose locations are no longer known
by some estimates they emit more than 7
million metric tons of greenhouse gases
per year
that's the equivalent of burning 30
million liters of petrol this is kind of
low hanging fruit if you would so this
is an area that we can take immediate
action so far curtis shucks non-profit
organization has plugged 16 abandoned
wells in four states methane is such an
incredibly harmful greenhouse gas it is
80 times as
destructive as co2
and so if you want to have an immediate
impact
you just stop it many of the wells that
well done has plugged are in open fields
the cleveland well project is different
we have elderly folks who live right
around it that's a tricky location to
rig up on
it's a tricky location to get into
the expert crew applies a seal to the
outflow pipe and welds it shut next
they'll drill down to clear debris and
dirt out of the pipe extending far below
the surface
in the final step the crew will fill the
well with a specially formulated kind of
cement
sealing it up forever and that's one
well down
2 million to go
for shock each plugged well is a triumph
how do you climb a mountain it's you
know one step at a time
that's really the focus is then that way
it becomes something that we can really
get our hands around and celebrate a
victory for the crew the community and
for the planet rob reynolds al jazeera
cleveland ohio